[Music]
I'd say don't give up keep playing and
also just play for fun not exactly to
win or anything just enjoy the
experience of playing every game and
hopefully winning
um I would advise that they enjoy the
game because I think that if you enjoy
the game then you will like genuinely be
able to improve naturally and uh your
hard work you will put in the hard work
um and just like to appreciate like
chess it's a really amazing game there's
so many possibilities like each game is
different basically and
um yeah so just like enjoy the game and
your improvement should become should
come naturally from there I think to get
better you just need to love the love
chess as a whole I feel like it's really
difficult
um to like get better if you have a lot
of trouble like trying to be
self-motivated or work by yourself so
I'd say don't give up and keep going
probably hopefully just learn to develop
your pieces and Castle I still have
trouble with that sometimes so like just
stick to the basics
honestly it's just like enjoy this game
like two and to like not to like worry
about like what what others like you
know like just like play play your best
definitely tactics some even like above
like reading chess books or studying
openings and all that just mostly
tactics recognizing positions and then
just like playing in tournaments um
playing wherever you can that's really
what I did honestly I would say try to
like play chess on your own terms
um I know I struggled a lot with that
um just like don't
um focus on just trying to like impress
everyone else play it because you love
the game and actually enjoy it I'll do
plenty of tactics oh and the main thing
is that you have to play a lot try to
play in as many tournaments as possible
and also play online games which should
help I would say you know if it's like
their first time playing Juniors I know
it's like a really almost like a
stressful experience to have your games
be on on like
um almost National stage and I remember
the first time I played here in St Louis
and junior girls I did not do so hot I
actually did really badly
um so I just said like kind of take it
easy enjoy the time you have here
um yeah enjoy the games that you play
you don't really know if you're gonna if
you like something until you try it so
you know chess really started to like
become really big during covid and you
know if you start playing an in-person
tournament that's when you start to
really figure out if you really like
playing chess so my advice is go plan
some in-person tournaments especially
since we're in St Louis this is the
perfect opportunity to come and play
[Music]
foreign